the man to my left the Pro Football Hall
of Famer Heisman Trophy winner 2-time
Super Bowl champion and MVP of Super
Bowl six from the Dallas Cowboys care of
Isis Roger Staubach good to see you sir
good to see that's an applause man oh my
god I think it all excited to see
Rodgers cover or wait a minute
Mike can you can you give me the proper
music to set up what I said please go
ahead and hit it it gets a little better
this way
he is a pro Football Hall of Famer and
Heisman Trophy winner two-time Super
Bowl champion an MVP of Super Bowl six
care of Isis larger I don't see any
cowboy jerseys over there yeah I know
there would have been I guess if the
Cowboys had made it you know I'm for
sure
there definitely would have been but
there are Cowboys fans everywhere and
obviously your your a major reason why
having built the Cowboys up from the
ground floor back in the day when they
first were called America's team now
that you're here at Super Bowl 53 asking
the MVP of Super Bowl six I mean what
was it like back in the day at the Super
Bowl nothing like what we're seeing
today
well the Super Bowls have just continued
to grow every year I was still in the
Navy when the Cowboys were had they lost
to Green Bay and the Ice Bowl and I
think the Super Bowl started back then
Packers won two years in a row and and
then when I joined the the Cowboys we
were in the 70s we were in the hunt all
the time and we were in five Super Bowls
we won two of them and we lost to the
Steelers a couple of times and and I'm
the other one I didn't get a chance to
play and I was on the bench but that was
against Baltimore so it's it's it's hard
to believe how how it's grown to where
it is today even back then it was it was
a big deal but today it's uh it's it's
all over the place it's much much more
I think TV the TV ratings everything is
just much more bigger on everybody's
looking forward to the Super Bowl
so was it it was there like a big media
hype presence yeah there was and we knew
we'd get there a week earlier and we'd
have a media day and it was you know
grad joy I want this Super Bowl 13 so
that's quite a while ago but it's it
still was
was those are you know it's a big deal
do you remember who the halftime act of
Super Bowl six was not Super Bowl six
the halftime and yes in Tulane where you
played do you remember or you don't know
was that you there's no it's definitely
not me I was a I was in the locker room
I don't know it was it was Ella
Fitzgerald Oh Harold Channing no and Al
Hirt is that right and the US Marine
Corps drill team in a salute to Louis
Armstrong oh wow yeah
a little bit different now yeah I like I
like New Orleans a lot we won twice in
New Orleans and we lost in Miami so to
the Steelers but we won in New Orleans
so I have a you know you have your
favorite places remember in New Orleans
was it was a soup after we won
in Super Bowl six when we beat Miami my
cuz shortly before my mother passed away
and she really had a blast at the Super
Bowl
I can still we were we did the two of us
were behind some money on a motorcycle
driving around New Orleans and she was I
could not believe she got on the
motorcycle she was so happy that we won
the Super Bowl and I got the MVP because
Dewayne Thomas wouldn't talk to anybody
so what do you mean well he had a great
game we had you know I had a good game
and Dewayne ran the ball very well our
offense Calvin Hill and Dwayne Thomas
but Dwayne that he was a great player
but he just wouldn't talk to the media
and everything I think if he did he
would have he would have got the vote
for MVP
now when you mentioned Calvin Hill I've
not asked you this question because
we've heard about it from Grant Hill is
it true you named Grant Hill by
suggesting the name to Calvin's yeah
they were having a hard time he and
Janet were just going crazy about a name
and and so they were Calvin's dad was
grant and her Henry
and so they were going back and forth
and I said well just naming grant Henry
Hill and that way you get everything in
there and they say that was after two
days so finally he was named grant Henry
Hill and so I was responsible you I had
yeah that's unbelievable
he wasn't my son but I was about six I
mean if you named anybody else the only
person you've helped named Roger well
our five kids okay then our 15 grandkids
I haven't helped them those but on our
kids I actually helped us was Landry any
different Super Bowl week yes he was he
it was first of all we said he was
intense he wasn't he was an engineer you
know he had goals outstanding reasonable
believable achievable they were measured
and he was an engineer and he his
preparation was his strength that's why
we won for twenty years in a row we were
well prepared but on the field things
had to happen you know he allowed me to
run he hated me running to begin in and
he said even my last year with the team
he were watching film and he said Roger
you got to stop that running I said well
coach I'll be retiring pretty soon okay
so so so he put up with that but he just
he believed and you drop back you read
your keys and you throw the football
that's exactly how Brady does it it was
fantastic at what he does
but he really was in preparation he was
he just was a great coach as far as how
he prepared so that was his that was his
his his way of things and in mine was a
little different I just wanted to go out
and win and run and do things and we got
along really well because he knew I
wanted to win and the players believed
in me and so he put up actually put up
with me those first few years I thought
he was gonna trade me and but we won the
Super Bowl in 71 and that helped a lot
he felt you thought Roger Staubach you
thought Tom Landry was gonna treat you
well I really did yeah I thought he I
was not you know I wasn't a pocket just
straight pocket passer but he really he
was creative we put the shotgun in in 75
because you know I he knew I could run a
little bit we ran from the shotgun a few
times but we also had it in note no one
else had the shotgun isn't that amazing
you know now now you see the shotgun on
every banya on on fourth and inches
people go on a shotgun but he but he was
creative and he
we had motion you know like Drew Pearson
was in motion all the time what the
defensive backs used to get up on top of
the wide receivers and just you know
just hit him off the line of scrimmage
and keep running with him that way
so he put one in motion which you were
legally you could have one in motion so
he couldn't get hit off the line of
scrimmage so that became that was we
were the only team with had anybody in
motion too and so coach Landry was
really creative he was a really good xno
coach and the emotion side of it and
what goes on on the field and everything
else that was taken over by the Leroy
Jordans and Bob lilies and you know and
hopefully myself on offense sure
absolutely and then it's interesting you
mentioned how you were in the Navy
during the Ice Bowl and obviously an MVP
of Super Bowl six a champion a second
time less than a decade later the fact
that we're seeing Brady in his ninth
Super Bowl you're the perfect person to
ask since you've seen a lot you played
against many people say he's the
undisputed greatest of all time what do
you think well what was one of the
things really hard to predict obviously
is drafting a quarterback I mean there's
some that are obvious and you know Troy
Aikman with Dallas was one of the best
drafts ever and but they knew that right
away but you know Brady was taken in the
sixth round and they they obviously
didn't understand with his strengths or
he would have been drafted sooner and
his strengths or he's got he's got a
very good arm but he he gets rid of the
ball quickly he sees what's going on and
he evidently understands what's going on
more than most quarterbacks because he
gets gets rid of that ball quickly it's
hard it's hard to sack him and he's not
he doesn't run he doesn't really buy
time run around but he does it with his
mind and in reading the keys on defense
he can tell when it's own man-to-man and
he knows that the receivers no one to
hook up on a on his own and and you know
make the break on a man-to-man and he he
gets rid of the ball and he picks out
that receiver whether it's Gronk or
Edelman whoever it is so is that he
guess he yes he he he's AM a he's a he's
really the best at
being able to get rid of that ball and
knowing what's going on there then and
he's got you know he's in he's a good
athlete he's stays in great shape yeah I
mean you you played to your 37 I mean
this man's a 41 year old now he has
never known what it's like to be a 40
year old not finishing up in the Super
Bowl he was a 40 year old last year and
he's gonna have 41 year old right now
it's nobody you know 41 if you if you
stay in shape you're you know III had
some concussion issues I was just
turning 38 and and I saw I played 11
years and I was told by dr. Fred Palmer
at Cornell Medical School that I should
the next one could be the real problem
in your life you've had too many of them
so I retired then but I was still
playing physically at a very good level
then cuz I stayed in shape and and
that's what Brady it's it's you know
he's talked about a bad game because
he's 41 years old with it he had a bad
game when he was 30 so he still is
playing great football at his age and he
just needs to not listen to people that
tell him how old he is to just get out
there and keep doing what he's doing
well in terms of concussions we'll get
to the vises helmet in a second but I do
want to ask you Roger Staubach about the
current state of the cowboys you
mentioned how Aikman was a surefire
quarterback draft pick but he was a 1st
overall pick and you mentioned where
Brady was in the 6th what about a 4th
round draft choice in dak you believe
he's the future challenge I think dak is
going to be and continue to be a
quarterback that's getting better every
year I think he's a very good
quarterback and the thing about dak is
that he he truly has confidence in
himself and he transfers transfers that
compass to his team it's his teammates
really believe in him everything that
you hear yeah and when I say interviewed
by players they love him they know that
and he's come through in the fourth
quarter he never quits never blames
anybody else so he's a leader and you
know for every bad pass he throws I mean
everybody there they're usually early in
the game he's he's he's pretty well in
the game and he's got a good winning
record so I
I'm disappointed in the question marks
on on DAC in his his strength and I
think his future is gonna be very good I
think
I think he's he'll be the Dallas
quarterback for a number of years are
you surprised that Jason Garrett is
gonna have to coach without in a
contract extension next year I you know
I've someone mentioned that I'm I'm
thinking all day and I hope went in
there and said hey listen I'm gonna
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna go
to the Super Bowl next year so don't
worry about my contract
I don't need extended contract but so he
needs to have a good year next year and
III hope Jason does cuz I like Jason and
he's done some good things in Dallas but
this will be a big year for the whole
team the whole team it's a good football
team so this coming year is gonna be a
big year and it's gonna be a big year
for Jason as far as his future as a with
Dallas probably like you know Jerry
right I mean Jerry is essentially kind
of putting everyone on notice he knows
exactly what he's doing I think he
realize that in a way don't you think
well I I don't know I'm not but Jerry is
he's a competitor he wants to win and he
but he is he is loyal to players the one
thing about the Jones family they're
very generous people they do a lot in
the community they they care about other
people and in in I think I think Jerry
cares about Jason wants to handle it the
way is should handle things but you also
have to make some tough decisions and
yet I think he believes a Jason you can
get things turned around next year yeah
now do you think the right decision was
made with Scott Linehan bringing in a 29
year old coordinator now and Kalyn more
well I wish I was I wish I was you know
there cuz I don't understand the inner
workings of some of the coaches there
I've heard more on just great things
about him what a smart kid he is a good
exit no guy and
I go back and tonight I'm having dinner
with Dan Reeves and Dan Reeves was
fantastic he was a player for us then he
became the backfield coach quarterback
coach
we certainly know him here in this and
he really helped helped me a lot he did
a great job and in Denver obviously the
Super Bowls they went to and then he was
here in Atlanta but so Dan Dan really
meant a whole lot to me as a as a coach
and so that's a very important position
and evidently Moore is gonna be the one
to take over on to really help that get
to the next next level also Rajasthan
back here on the Rich Eisen show before
I let you go we've got the vices helmet
right here
Russell Wilson Patrick mahomes Doug
Baldwin Golden Tate in over a hundred
NFL players are wearing it since it
launched last year what are you what do
you say about this helmet that actually
helps with what caused you and obviously
Troy Aikman it seems to retire it's a
great helmet I mean it's it's the NFL
has recognized it in a very positive way
that's why you're seeing you know it's
in a lot of colleges now in high schools
and you know I wear it all the time with
our 15 grandkids so it's it's it's just
it's a great helmet I mean that the
helmet the helmet isn't gonna be the
total answer for concussions but it's
gonna be helped
my first helmet was a leather helmet in
high school we emulated Notre Dame and
Notre Dame had leather helmets at that
time so I had my first concussion my
leather helmet had a couple with not a
great helmet it did Navy for a while
then they build a special helmet for me
where they patted it and so when I was
with Dallas
so this helmet is is really try to tries
to prevent the brain from getting
knocked around a little bit well I mean
your post-playing career has been a
model for so many other players have you
had any effects at all do you have
effects of concussion after playing the
game Roger from time to time no George I
haven't highs well done
well no it's that's not funny anymore I
don't think but you know I know I'm not
gonna would I'm feel fine I mean
sometimes I my wife says I might forget
something that I shouldn't forget but
usually I do it intentionally nice
plannin home Roger I want to go
everything's being investigating now the
CTE and there's a lot of I've got a
number of teammates that have have a
very severe dementia so there's there's
probably something too in sports I'd
like to see young kids be played to
everybody played touch football for a
while until they get older older than
they then they could play and then some
kids are playing touch football but it's
hard if you're just plain touched and
all of a sudden you get in high school
and somebody else has been playing been
hitting so so it's it it it's being
investigated and I think they're trying
to do more with the rules with it with
the equipment but the this the CTE thing
is it will get better understood when
it's not just players that that have
died that they they do the testing so it
it's it's a serious issue concussions
and in your brain has got to heal like
anything else so they're keeping players
out when I had Mike and you know I get
knocked out a number of times then you
have the dingers where you just get
confused but you need to come out when
you have a dinger oh and you're confused
and even though you start thinking
against your brain he hasn't really
healed yet right so today they're
they're doing a much better job of
keeping players out of the game might
even skip a couple weeks so they're it's
going the right direction but football
is one tough sport and force equals mass
times acceleration I I used to plug that
the naval Kenny with a slide rule by the
way so so four players are bigger and
faster so the forces is greater today
you get hit harder today than even in
the old day so well you got the vises
helmet here and it's a thrill to have
you here Roger
Bailey it's really I'm honored whenever
you uh you know call in or stop by it's
it's great so thanks for being here
thank you off the Friday program Roger
Staubach is right here
on the Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience